and today I have the privilege of
introducing our speaker dr. Yuval Levin
who's the Hertog fellow at the ethics
and Public Policy Center mr. Levin
earned his BA from American University
and his PhD from the University of
Chicago his essays and articles have
been has been featured in numerous
publications including the New York
Times The Washington Post The Wall
Street Journal Time Newsweek and
commentary he is the founding editor of
the national affairs a senior editor at
the New Atlantis a contributing editor
of National Review and the author of
imagining the future science and the
American democracy in addition dr. Levin
has book forthcoming on December 3rd
it's entitled the great debate Edmund
Burke Thomas Paine and the birth of the
right and left and it's me speaking to
you about that today so without further
ado dr. Levin
thank you very much appreciate that
enormously it's always wonderful to be
among friends and a very great honor to
be at Hillsdale Washington campus and to
take part in this lecture series I've
been a great admirer of Hillsdale for a
long time as everybody ought to be and
really love what you do in Washington
and especially now that you've got Matt
Spaulding heading up your DC program
here I'm sure you know what a great
treasure you have and Matt and how lucky
Hillsdale is to have lured him here he's
really a force for good like nobody else
in Washington and especially for those
of us who try to work at the
intersection of theory and practice in
Washington Matt is really a model and an
inspiration and Hillsdale is an
inspiration what I want to do today is
really precisely to try to shed some
light on that intersection of theory and
practice to think about what lies
beneath our politics and how it shapes
what happens on the surface because on
its surface American politics these days
can seem just impossibly complicated we
face an enormous array of public policy
problems each of them is awfully
convoluted in itself and they don't seem
particularly well connected to one
another from health care and
entitlements and budgets to education
and transportation and energy and
abortion and marriage and cultural
issues how could anybody hope to
understand all of the intricate details
of all of these challenges and make any
sense of them I make my living as a kind
of combatant in some of these policy
debates I'm the editor of a quarterly
Journal and domestic policy I'm a
think-tank scholar I've worked on these
issues at the staff level on the hill
and at the White House and what I found
in doing that is that making sense of
these debates requires more than an
immersion in the technical details it
requires a sense of how the different
policy dilemmas that confront our
society hang together how they relate to
one another and why they divide us the
way they do the way that they divide us
after all is is not arbitrary it's not
by coincidence
that people who tend to agree with one
another on one set of issues say how to
deal with the deficit also seem to agree
with one another very frugally on other
issues that don't seem obviously
connected from education reform to
transportation and what-have-you there
are exceptions of course and there are
lots of interesting fissures within the
party coalition's but on the whole
conservatives and liberals and therefore
often Republicans and Democrats fairly
consistently find themselves on opposite
sides of contentious debates on a very
broad range of subjects so why is there
a right and a left that seemed to hang
together where do they come from
what really divides them fundamentally
my approach to that question starts from
the premise that politics is not a
cynical game most people don't get into
it out of venal motives or to take
anything from anybody and let alone
people who are not in politics but just
have views that put them on the right or
the left it's hard to imagine why they
would have those views to serve some
interest group they have those views for
other reasons your views about politics
at the end of the day are really an
expression of a deep worldview the
complicated policy debates that take
place at the surface of our politics are
moved by deeper questions that can
actually be maybe ironically a lot more
accessible to average citizens than
those technical debates moral and
philosophical questions about what each
of us takes to be true and important
about human life and what that means for
our expectations of politics we may not
think about these deeper questions
explicitly every time that we confront a
contemporary political issue but how we
answer these sorts of questions shapes
the way that we approach the great
political debates of the day these
deeper questions can be difficult to get
at but one way to try to get at them is
to seek out their origins in the history
of our political thought to see where
the left and rights started and then to
think about how they've developed and
that's what this new book of mine tries
to do and what I'll try to do today is
give you a quick kind of whirlwind tour
of that and the book of course gets into
the details and into the philosophical
arguments underlying it at greater depth
there's a familiar cliche about where
the left and the right come from they
come from the French Revolution right
Marais that's true
certainly the terms left and right
actually do come from the seating
arrangements at the National Assembly
after the Revolution
are the radicals who supported the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and the
citizen sat to the left of the speaker
their opponents who were still fairly
radical but were a little less so set to
the right of the speaker and left and
right came to represent those two ways
of thinking but the idea that those
became our left and right is really too
much of a cliche and doesn't tell us
enough about what left and right really
mean the actual parties to the french
revolutions the jacobins and the
journalists and the monarchists and
aristocrats don't really bear much
resemblance to what we actually find in
our own politics it is true though I
think that the modern left and right
emerged at that time in that period but
they emerged not in the course of the
French Revolution but rather in the
anglo-american debate about the
revolution an intense debate about the
character of politics in the nature of
political change that dominated the late
18th century in Britain in America
starting well before the French
Revolution encompassing the period of
the American Revolution then very
evident in it and then really exploding
on to the surface in the course of the
English and American debates about what
was happening in France that period
roughly 1770 to 1800s so a lot of the
basic concepts and terms and divisions
and arguments that still define our
political life burst into the world all
at once and the parties to that debate a
party of justice and a party of order or
a party of progress and a party of
conservation do bear a plain paternal
resemblance to the parties of our own
time there are no perfect
representatives of the parties to that
debate but I think there may be no
better representatives for our purposes
than edmund burke and thomas paine and i
try to look at that debate at its
origins through their disagreement
Edmund Burke lived from 1729 to 1797 he
was an Irish born English politician and
writer a man of intense opinions with an
extraordinary gift for expressing them
in political rhetoric and really his
eras most devoted and able defender of
the inherited traditions of the English
Constitution he was a patient gradual
reformer of his country's institutions
and he was among the first and certainly
the most adamant
ineffective critics of the radicalism of
the French Revolution English politics
Thomas Paine lived at just about the
same time from 1737 to 1809 they're very
much contemporaries he was an English
born immigrant to America who became one
of the most eloquent and important
voices championing the cause of
independence for the colonies and then
as revolution brewed in France became an
influential advocate of the
revolutionaries cause in Paris and in
London he was a fantastic political
writer a master of rhetoric and he was a
fervent believer in the potential of
enlightenment liberalism to advance the
cause of justice and peace by uprooting
corrupt regimes and replacing them with
governments that were answerable to the
people Burke and pain were both
political thinkers and political actors
at the same time and each of them also
saw in the debates of their age much
more than the particular details of the
events that launched them they knew that
these arguments were about deeper
questions the two of them knew each
other they met several times they
exchanged a lot of letters they publicly
answered one another's published
writings and their profound disagreement
extends well beyond their direct
confrontations each of them voiced a
worldview that was deeply at odds with
the other over some of the most
important questions of Liberal
Democratic political thought and in a
lot of ways Paine embodied the
progressive spirit of the radicals of
his age and Burke gave voice to the
opposing more conservative vision of
liberalism in his time their
disagreement though it was always
directed to real events and practical
questions took place much of the time on
the plane of philosophical argument they
argued about the meaning of nature and
history and politics about what sort of
standard of Justice should guide
political life they argued about the
tension between rights and duties in
society between choice and obligation
they argued about whether politics could
answer two stark universal principles
that we could grasp through Pure Reason
or whether it had to take as its guide
the traditions and forms and inherited
practices of each society their debates
blended theory and practice philosophy
and politics and I talked about them at
some length in the book but what I can
what I want to sketch out for you here
are really
three general patterns in their
disagreement that their arguments always
seem to fall into and it might help to
clarify both what it came down to and
what might what it might tell us about
our own time in our own politics these
three broad disputes between them have
to do with their basic disposition
towards society and politics on the one
hand with their sense of what kind of
knowledge is available to us to solve
political and social problems and how it
could be applied and finally with their
views of how the past and the present
relate to one another in politics and in
human life more generally a question
that gets to what may well be the
deepest difference between them and
between the right and the left and each
of these three broad disagreements can
help us understand an element of our own
politics the first can help us think
about what gets the left and the right
energized or angry the second can help
us see how conservatives and liberals
tend to think about economic issues and
the third can help us see how we tend to
think about social issues and why all
these are related to one another
so first then Burke and Paine exhibit
very different basic dispositions toward
the world as they find it the world is
necessarily an imperfect world every
society has both good and bad things
about it institutions that work well
institutions that don't a mix of success
and failure
Edmund Burke like a lot of conservatives
after him approached the world by first
and foremost being impressed with and
grateful for what works and so trying to
build on what's good to address what's
not Thomas Paine liked a lot of
progressives in radical sense approached
that world by first and foremost being
struck and outraged at what was failing
and so trying to root out the bad to
make room for the good to take its place
Burke begins ingratitude pain begins in
outrage now that doesn't mean that Burke
is never outraged he's outraged quite a
lot actually and especially around the
French Revolution but he's outraged when
he sees something that he values being
undone or threatened his outrage is a
function of his gratitude for the given
pain on the other hand is outraged at
the failures of long-standing
institutions that the persistence of
failure his outrage is directed at the
status quo
these starting dispositions are grounded
in their very different expectations of
human beings Burk begins with a sense of
man as a fallen creature as highly
imperfect prone to self-destructive
passions and excesses and in need of
Correction and balance and that means
that he's basically excuse me that he's
basically surprised that anything works
at all in society
he thinks it's much easier for human
communities to fall into chaos and
disorder than to achieve order and
happiness and any human institutions
that do manage to work that makes
something worthwhile of this imperfect
raw material of man should be revered
and treasured and protected he's
grateful for those institutions grateful
for the people who created and sustained
them because he thinks that institutions
like those are very far from guaranteed
pain on the contrary Begins for much
higher expectations of human reason than
human power and knowledge and so he
thinks that achieving social order and
tranquility and happiness is a matter of
applying the right principles principles
that he thought were becoming well-known
in his time thanks to the new
enlightenment science of politics and so
there was really no excuse for
persisting and failure social order and
prosperity and peace should be the
default condition of the human race and
any deviations from it are a reason to
be outraged his expectations are almost
utopian where Burks are far lower and
more modest
and so pain is inclined to tear down
what isn't working and is confident that
it can be replaced with something better
while burke is cautious to protect
standing institutions he thinks they
were built over generations of trial and
error by countless people working
together to address enduring human
problems and so he wants to preserve
those institutions and to fix their
problems and targeted and modest ways
because he's not at all sure he could
build new or better ones from scratch
here we find I think a basic difference
of disposition that is still very much
evident in our politics today one
approach that begins in gratitude for
the good in the world another that
begins an outrage at the bad the first
seeks gradual reform to sustain a
working system
the second seeks wholesale
transformation to move beyond a failing
system and create a working one so one
is conservative the other progressive
one is outraged at seeing valuable
possessions lost the other is outraged
at the injustice of the status quo but
it's not that simple
not at all we do after all a lot of
times see conservatives today eager to
transform some of our governing
institutions our public programs in very
profound ways and we do sometimes found
especially these days liberals who are
downright protective of existing
government programs and resisting change
the right does basically begin in
gratitude for the good and skepticism
about our ability to rebuild society
from scratch and the left at outrage at
perceived injustice and confidence in
our ability to do a lot better but they
also differ about the sorts of governing
institutions that we should have and
what their purpose should be a
difference that explains I think a lot
of our politics now this second
difference which is also very evident in
Birken pain follows directly from the
first but it's a difference of opinion
about what kind of knowledge is
available to us in politics and society
pain because he believed in a
transformative politics made possible by
a new science of society that was
discovered or developed in the
Enlightenment thought that politics
existed in large part to enable the
application of that kind of technical
knowledge and expertise to social
problems
he thought politics should be applied
principle and so our political
institutions should first of all embody
the principles of equality and liberty
and so should be democratic institutions
which should also enable the application
of new scientific knowledge to society
and to its social problems politics for
him should make room for a kind of
applied science of governing Burke as
we've already seen had a very different
view of the potential of human knowledge
in power he thought scientific knowledge
of society was overrated that human
lives and human problems were much too
complicated to be amenable to simple or
technical solutions and that again the
institutions that had grown up in
society over many generations had grown
up through a process of trial and error
in the effort to address exactly the
kinds of timeless problems that we now
are dealing with a kind of evolutionary
process and so they were extremely
well adapted to addressing social
problems there was a much better chance
that these kinds of social institutions
which channeled the dispersed social
knowledge of many rather than applying
the concentrated technical knowledge of
a few could address the complicated
problems we have in society these sorts
of evolved institutional forms included
everything from social institutions like
the family itself and the various
different local organizations and
arrangements different communities made
for themselves
all the way to political institutions
that over long stretches of time had
developed various complicated practices
and traditions that often didn't make
much logical sense on the face of it but
that seemed to work for pain
institutions like these were often just
vestiges of backwardness and Prejudice
if they couldn't justify their forms and
practices explicitly through abstract
reason and logic then they didn't
deserve to continue Society couldn't
hope to become rational if it let itself
be weighted down by practices and
institutions that we just retain out of
habit and worse than that these kinds of
traditional institutions often
perpetuated prejudices that were
unbecoming of a modern society
he was particularly critical of the
various non-political institutions that
stood between the individual in the
state the institutions that we would
think of as civil society which he
described as a kind of wilderness of
Turnpike gates standing between the
individual and his rights these
institutions just created pockets of
power that were not legitimate in a
democracy and stood in the way of the
elected government applying its rational
ideas sanctioned by the people to
address social problems burke insisted
that just because they couldn't justify
themselves in terms of Paynes radical
principles didn't mean that institutions
like these couldn't justify themselves
by the proof of the good they had done
in the world of the fact that they
worked to meet people's actual needs and
desires again he was critical of the
notion that we knew everything we needed
to know to make a perfect society he
thought a lot of the knowledge that
makes society possible was contained in
this in the forms and structures of
institutions like these no one could
claim to really possess that knowledge
and yet we all could benefit from it
this difference in
about the kind of knowledge that should
guide society is I think also very
powerfully evident in our own politics
the left still tends to incline toward a
confidence in technical knowledge in a
belief that the purpose of politics is
largely to enable the application of
expertise to solve social problems the
right still inclines toward trusting
dispersed social knowledge organized by
social institutions from markets and
civil society to the family that make it
possible for our society as a whole to
be wiser and practice than any of its
members in fact this helps explain why
conservatives today are so often trying
to transform large institutions and
liberals are so often trying to protect
them the reason is that the particular
institutions in question the
institutions of the liberal welfare
state created mostly in the middle of
the last century are embodiments of the
left's approach to social policy the
debate about preserving or transforming
our entitlement system and other key
governing programs now is a kind of
second order argument about political
change a debate about reforming a set of
welfare state institutions that are
themselves intended to advance a certain
kind of social vision and that vision is
a progressive archetype that pain would
have recognized and a gala Terry and
ideal of justice advanced through the
application of text of technical
expertise regarding society within a
liberal framework opposing it is a more
conservative ideal that Burke would have
recognized a case for addressing social
problems through evolved institutions
like the family and civil society
religious groups and markets the tacitly
contain and convey implicit knowledge
within a liberal framework conservatives
today want to transform institutions of
the first type into institutions of the
second type that is basically what the
conservative reform agenda amounts to
it's very much I think another instance
of the general pattern of ideological
division that we can trace back to the
era of the founding in the French
Revolution the healthcare debate offers
what may be the clearest example of this
point it is really a debate about how to
solve a complex social problem by
empowering expert knowledge or by
empowering social knowledge at the core
of that kind of debate is a very old
difference of opinion about what kind of
knowledge is available to us
and again pains confident faith in
expert technical knowledge points to a
vision of government as applying
expertise to social problems and Burkes
humble preference for dispersed social
knowledge points to a vision of
government as sustaining the space in
which society gradually builds on its
strengths to improve itself it is a
difference that's powerfully evident in
a lot of contemporary debates especially
economic ones
finally the Burke Paine debate also
makes it clear that this difference
about what we can hope to know
translates into a difference about what
sort of respect in regard we should have
for society's traditions and habits for
what we inherit from past generations
that question was in fact absolutely
central to the heated dispute between
Burke and Payne it is the unifying theme
of their debate again and again arising
in disagreements over seeming seemingly
different subjects this is the third and
maybe the most important of the broad
themes that I would want to pull out of
the details of their dispute Payne's
theory of politics begins in a kind of
state of nature argument that we might
recognize from john locke with free and
independent individuals choosing to form
a society to protect themselves and
their rights that means that he takes
society to be answerable to stark
principles that basically treat every
human individual as entirely independent
and thoroughly free to choose society is
a choice and its purpose is to protect
our freedom to make other choices that
means that it can't allow us to be
hemmed in by choices made by our
forefathers anymore than those made by
our neighbors we have to think of every
individual as though he chose to create
our society from scratch to protect his
own rights and therefore as though he
wasn't born into a society full of
traditions that he had nothing to do
with Paine was extremely clear and
explicit about this very unusual
argument in his book the rights of man
written in 1790 in direct response to
Burke's reflections on the revolution in
France Paine wrote this I'll quote the
illuminating and divine principle of the
equal rights of man relates not only to
living individuals but to generations of
men succeeding each other every
generation is equal in rights to
generations which preceded it by the
same
rule that every individual is born equal
in rights with his contemporary all men
are born equal and with equal natural
right in the same manner as if posterity
had been continued by creation instead
of generation the latter being only the
mode by which the former is carried
forward and consequently every child
born into the world must be considered
as deriving its existence from God the
world is as new to him as it was to the
first man that existed and his natural
right in it is of the same kind this
outright denial of the significance of
generations and of the way human beings
come into the world is in a sense a
natural conclusion of a political theory
that begins in a Lockean state of nature
but pain was driven precisely by his
dispute with Burke to make it utterly
explicit and Burke in turn was driven by
pains clarity to better understand the
foundation of his own political thought
he shows us that conservatism is rooted
in a very different understanding of
beginnings than the one we normally
associate with the liberal society in an
essay called an appeal from the new to
the old Whigs written in 1791
largely in direct response to pains
rights of man Burke answer specifically
Payne's denial of the significance of
generations in social life in an
extraordinary passage that for my money
is the most important paragraph in all
of Burke's immense volume of writings he
comes closest to giving us his basic
anthropology I'll quote it dark and
inscrutable are the ways by which we
come into the world the instincts that
give rise to this mysterious process of
nature are not of our making but out of
physical causes unknown to us perhaps
unknowable arise moral duties which as
we are able perfectly to comprehend we
are bound indispensably to perform
parents may not be consenting to their
moral relations but consenting or not
they are bound to a long train of
burdensome duties toward those with whom
they have never made a contract of any
sort
children are not consenting to their
relation but their relation without
their consent binds them to its duties
rather it implies their consent because
the presumed consent of every rational
creature is in unison with the
predisposed order of things men come in
that manner into a community
with the social state of their parents
endowed with all the benefits loaded
with all the duties of their situation
if the social ties and ligaments spun
out of those physical relations which
are the elements of the Commonwealth in
most cases begin and always continue
independently of our will so without any
stipulation on our part our rebound by
that relation called our country which
comprehends as it has been well said all
the charities of all nor are we left
without powerful instincts to make this
duty as dear and grateful to us as it is
awful and coercive and quo in other
words society flows out of local
relations which flow out of family
relations which flow out of the basic
reality that each of us is born into a
world that exists before us and the fact
that human beings enter the world this
way creates a whole web of obligations
that are binding even though they are
not chosen an enormous portion of Burks
and I think of the conservative
worldview becomes clear in light of the
importance he places on the basic facts
and character of human procreation and
an enormous portion of pains in the
progressive worldview becomes clearer in
light of the desire he expresses to be
liberated from the implications of those
facts in that character a great many of
what we loosely call the social issues
have to do with a dispute about whether
that kind of liberation is possible and
desirable whether the obligations that
result from the way people come into
being in this life can be made merely
optional Brooke takes the human person
to be embedded in a web of obligations
that gives shape to our lives from our
most intimate family relations to the
form and function of our social and
political institution while Payne thinks
that all such obligations have to be
made matters of choice these three
overarching sets of differences
different dispositions toward the good
and bad in society different
expectations of human knowledge and
power and different views of how much of
a choice we really have about our
obligations to past and future
generations
shape the Burke paine debate and in many
ways continue to shape the debate
between the right and the left today
they point to two different ways of
understanding our liberal
society one way pains way see society is
answering to clear rational principles
discovered or developed in the
Enlightenment that when applied will
enable our key social problems to be
addressed and so enable for an
extraordinary degree of individual
liberty and choice the work of society
is therefore the work of further and
further applying these principles and
progressing toward that end the other
way Burke's way sees society is a
product of countless generations of
gradual political and cultural evolution
in the West which by the time of the
Enlightenment and especially in Britain
had begun to arrive at political forums
that allowed for a workable balance
between freedom and effective government
given the constraints of human nature
and that offered us a sense of what the
principles of justice that ought to
guide political life might be the work
of society is therefore the work of
preserving and refining these forms to
make them even better suited to our
ideals and goals these two visions of
society are not polar opposites both
speak to the kind of liberal democratic
society that we inhabit but they are
profoundly different and our vision is
and one vision is plainly progressive
while the other is plainly conservative
seeing how these two visions took shape
in the birth pain debate in the late
18th century
doesn't tell us all we need to know
about politics obviously things have
changed a lot since then the left and
the right have changed a lot since then
but seeing these roots of our political
order does help us to make sense of the
contours of our political life to see
where our politics come from and what
it's about and it helps us to see the
political differences are neither
shallow nor cynical they're about deep
and difficult questions they're serious
and politics is serious even if our
politicians don't always seem to know
that Hillsdale College has always known
that and tried to teach it so I'm
especially glad to be taking up these
questions here today with you and very
eager to know what you make of them
Thanks
I probably don't need a mic but I got
one anyhow thank you very much thank you
all kinds of things up in the head but
one one of the early parts was a
statement of Burke's
conventional vision of liberalism and
and a separate progressive vision of
liberalism you know and then through the
rest of your talk you used liberal and
liberalism of several times what would
you put some flesh on yeah thank you
that's a great question I had a long
sort of discussion of that in the book
that I was forced to put into a footnote
but it is in a footnote so it's there
for you it's a very important question
because obviously we use these terms in
somewhat different ways as a general
matter what I mean by liberalism in this
discussion is the free society is not
the left and is not the right but is the
kind of society that both Burke and pain
were in essence arguing in favor of but
for different reasons a liberal society
is society with free institutions
Society with freedom of with the right
to property with basic rights a society
that John Locke would have recognized as
a legitimate society Democratic to some
degree the Burke and Payne did disagree
about just how completely Democratic it
ought to be the term liberal has come to
refer now to the left to the opposite of
conservatism but one of the things I try
to do in the book is to describe a
conservative liberalism which i think is
Edmund Burke's view of the world and a
more radical liberalism which is Payne's
view of the world I think that their
debate the late 18th century debate is
that kind of debate of two of to
liberalism to understanding of what two
understandings of what liberalism is is
it a discovery of principles that have
to be fully applied so that society can
be transformed or is it an achievement
of Western civilization that is in
bodied in the kind of society you'd find
in Britain in America in the late 18th
century those two are very different
ways of thinking about what's
essentially the same thing that is is
the liberal society something that
should guide forward progress towards a
state beyond politics or is it in itself
the achievement we ought to preserve and
make more of I think that's an argument
within liberalism and in that sense the
left-right debate in the anglo-american
world is different now certainly was
different then from the left-right
debate in continental Europe where the
the imaginable boundaries were much
broader it was not a debate within
liberalism but a debate that was able to
contemplate much more radical
alternatives and that of course in in
fact in a lot of places ended up
pursuing much more radical alternatives
with disastrous results we've been
fortunate that in our country and in
this sort of Anglosphere more generally
politics is fought between the 40-yard
lines it's fought as an argument about
what liberalism is and what it's for we
are I think it's unfortunate that the
term liberalism a beautiful term has
come to be identified with one side of
the defining debate of the liberal
society but that's the way it is and so
I agree with you and using that term it
ought to be defined well thanks for your
talk can you respond to the
counter-argument or is there distinction
between the evolution of social
practices absorbed over time and what
some people call us tourism so it
stretches Leo Strauss as critique of
Burke as someone who trended toward the
historicist conception of politics in
relation to that with the rights of man
that pain espoused with a more Caesar
distinction between that that conception
of Rights and man and the rights that
were declared by the American founders
both great questions so I I would I
think I take Strauss this critique of
Burke to be more about how Burke was
read than about what Brooks said and
and there's probably some truth though I
think not much in the idea that a
certain reading of Berk helped
contribute to the historicism of the of
the Germans especially in the 19th
century I don't think that anything
Burke said or intended to say had much
to do with that at all
he certainly agreed that political life
had to be guided by political ideals and
principles and there are certain times
especially in his arguments about France
and in his arguments about Ireland and
India circumstances where he thought
that on the one hand the institutions of
the English Constitution were less
relevant because they were happening
elsewhere and also in part because the
departures from English history on the
part of the British themselves were very
radical and problematic you had to make
an appeal to larger principles where
Burke differed from some of the more
radical voices in his party and Burke
was a Whig he was not a Tory was in his
understanding of how he could come to
know those principles Brooke thought
that they could not be reached by by
logical abstraction that they couldn't
just be through sort of pure geometric
you know ratiocination you could arrive
at the proper principles of politics he
thought that our only means of really
accessing them was through the history
of a society that achieved a balance of
order and liberty
he thought Britain offered the best
example of that and he proceeded by
trying to understand the principles that
lay above politics by thinking about
what English politics had been in a
sense his argument was this that a
society that's trying to solve the right
kinds of problems will over time through
the through the practice and process of
its own history in effect kind of rub up
against the answer against those
principles because when it applies them
correctly things work when it doesn't it
finds itself in big trouble and so as it
does that it takes the shape of those
principles and so he tried to understand
the principles from that shape of his
Society because he thought there was not
readily available a more direct way to
understand those principles that's not a
store system that's not that's not the
notion that effectively that what
happens now is what should happen now
and Brooke certainly has a principled
theory of society but the the humility
that he has about our ability to know
the principles of justice is very
frustrating to a lot of us because as
you say and to get to your second
question Payne says those principles are
knowable directly if you think about
society as starting from the state of
nature and we say it was a free choice
made to protect other free choices the
rights to life liberty and property are
the things to be protected government
exists to protect those rights and when
it fails to protect them we have the
right to overthrow that government the
problem with that for Burke is that it
begins in a state of nature argument and
Brooks says well certainly no human
being has ever lived in that situation
so isn't it a little peculiar to base
everything that we believe about
government on a thought experiment that
doesn't really have anything to do with
anything
it is a little peculiar and the way he
thought about what Locke did was to say
that Locke was trying to justify
something that had already happened he
was trying to justify the British
constitution the English Constitution at
a time when it was very much in question
Locke was writing around the time of the
Glorious Revolution just before and
Brooke says
Locke took the existing English Society
and said one way to justify that without
having to worry about whether the
Catholics of the Protestants are right
is to say well these principles
protecting the individual protecting
life liberty and property are what
society has to be about because that is
what English society had come to be
about he says that's fine if your goal
is to justify an already existing
society without starting a religious war
but it's not true it's not actually how
we get to these things this is a
challenging argument for us Americans
because as you say that the Declaration
of Independence does begin with
basically an assertion of the sorts of
Rights that are I think almost exactly
what pay
would take to be the rights of man Paine
and Jefferson were close friends they
thought very much alike the Declaration
of Independence though goes on to say
other things it goes on to argue that
what the Americans are being denied is
essentially the preservation of their
existing political institutions that the
reason to declare independence is that
the British government was denying them
continuity was denying them their own
governments which they'd had for
generations
I think Burke was more inclined to the
second half of the Declaration of
Independence than the first but he
understood that this tension was
problematic and in fact Burke has very
very little to say about the Declaration
of Independence we actually know for a
fact that he was present in the House of
Commons when when the Declaration was
read aloud to the members but he never
writes a word about it not in his
private letters not in his public
writings he never mentions Jefferson he
has a lot to say about the Americans and
he knew a lot about a lot of individual
Americans he certainly had opinions
about Thomas Jefferson he doesn't
express them to our knowledge in
anything he wrote he tries to avoid that
question to avoid that tension it's not
so easy for us American conservatives to
avoid that tension we do face the
challenge of what conservatism looks
like in a society founded on a
revolution but I think there's a problem
with how we've tried to answer that
question I think that we incline when we
decide to turn philosophical we incline
to a kind of radical Jeffersonian ism
we're inclined to say our philosophy is
the most radical version of late 18th
century liberalism it just isn't there
actually is another argument for the
liberal society a genuinely conservative
liberalism there are not a lot of
exponents of it there are not a lot of
people who articulated it and that's why
I think recovering a certain
understanding of Burke is helpful to
American conservatives because he gives
us a way to think about what
conservatism is in a liberal society
that allows us to think about what
government is for that allows us to
think in constructive ways about what
public life is all about we're trying to
trying to frame an
conservatism on a foundation of radical
liberalism is very problematic and makes
it difficult for us to think about what
government is about what it should be
doing about governing at all I think
that's a problem that's very much alive
for us right now and so I think a
recovery of the actual conservative
tradition of anglo-american liberalism
could be helpful thank you what would
you make of cory robbins thesis in the
reactionary mind Inman Bert to Sarah
Palin where he basically asserts that
Burke is not the Burkean moderate that
we see but actually a potentially
violent reactionary leading a call to
arms against the french revolution in
light of the nature of the french
revolution yeah well i think III think
he offers a very close reading of
approximately four lines of the
reflections on the revolution in France
but there were other things said and
there was a context and I don't think
that honestly I don't think there's any
merit to that understanding of Burke
it's a very unusual understanding Brooke
there's a there's a frequent critique of
Burke that says that he started out as a
as a kind of radical and over time and
especially after the French Revolution
became more of a conservative I think
that misunderstanding of Burke is at
least a little easier to justify because
Brooke spends the beginning of his
career as a reformer and around the time
of the French Revolution becomes rather
vehemently a preserver of the English
Constitution he himself explains that
and I think quite plausibly and
correctly I mean I think his his
worldview holds together rather well in
that he thought that in both cases he
was trying to preserve the English
Constitution on the one hand from a kind
of standing inertia being forced on it
by the monarchy on the other hand by the
threat of radicalism from France and
elsewhere the argument that Burke offers
a kind of violent reaction ISM I think
it just doesn't make much sense
it doesn't make sense in its historical
context it doesn't make sense if even if
you just read Burke's writing as
philosophy as he tries to do so for what
that's worth that's what I think of it
yes thank you
where would you insert libertarianism in
this discussion it's a very great
question you know one way to think about
the implications of the Burke Payne
debate for our time is that it's
actually a debate that's happening
within the right in some ways that is
there's a lot of Thomas Paine that you
would find in contemporary
libertarianism it is a more direct
extension of that radical strand of
liberalism in some ways than
progressivism is the American Left went
through a went through a process by
which Jeffersonian ism became
progressivism I think we live with a we
live with at least a partial
misunderstanding of that process we tend
to attribute it to the German imports
more than we ought to and we tend to
deny the left its actual roots in the
American tradition but there definitely
was a process there by which the the the
mechanisms the means of Paynes kind of
radical liberalism was abandoned in
favor of the ends of the utopianism of
it libertarianism is in a sense what was
left is is is is more like classical
liberalism and so in a lot of ways it's
not fundamentally conservative it
doesn't share the skepticism about human
knowledge and power at least some
libertarianism and American liberty
terrorism is very complicated as I don't
have to tell a room like this and runs a
kind of a kind of gamut from from forms
that are quite close to conservatism and
there are conservatism two forms that
are actually quite radically liberal but
I think I think libertarianism helps
shed light on the distinctions that I
try to get at in that early debate
because it's a pure form of a kind of
classical liberalism than you find on
either the right or the left and so it
helps shed light on both the problems
and the strengths of that of that way of
thinking is a way to approach our
politics and you know a short and
unsatisfying answer is that it's
complicated
but it's that's true I I am I'm
wondering whether facts that have
emerged about procreation since this
debate bear it all and bear it all in
the debate and not only the facts of
genetics and and and you know fetal
development and and all that but also
that if you can call them the social
technologies that have emerged about
either adoption or the state being able
to support single motherhood and this
kind of thing whether that changes the
debate yeah and an actual bio
technologies this is roughly how Burk
led me into bioethics is the question
you're asking so I think the answer is
yes and no it bears on it in a sense
that MacCready the ways that Burke and
Paine talked about human procreation
which is very interesting it's a subject
that you don't really expect to come up
in a debate like this but it turns out
to be just absolutely central to it what
you come to realize is that the the
project of biotechnology especially as
it touches on procreation is absolutely
critical to the plausibility of a
certain kind of radical liberalism that
is the availability of a liberation from
the unchosen obligations that
procreation involves is essential to the
the utopian version of the liberal
project being possible it has to be true
that there's a way out of that and burks
basic assumption as you see in that
passage that I read to you and it's all
over is that no such liberation is
possible he also argues that it's not so
we ought to want because in fact that's
what gives shape to humanity but it's
certainly true that we've advanced
technologically in ways that now suggest
that at least as a practical matter that
kind of liberation is possible the way
the birth pain debate bears on that is
that it raises the question of what that
is liberation from is it just liberation
from burdensome obligations that we
ought to want to be free of so that we
could live more liberal lives or is it
liberation from the very form and shape
of human life so that breaking it
breaking these obligations would leave
us kind of unmoored from the foundations
of what our social institutions in our
and our history as human beings has been
all about I think that's why the biotech
debates are such profound debates and
they really are and they get it very
very deep questions and they move people
in in powerful ways that sometimes can
be very difficult to explain why you
know why the country would spend several
years obsessed with this debate over
stem cells there were a lot of reasons
it touched on the abortion debate a
touched on other things but of course
the abortion debate is also
understandable I think more clearly in
light of the of the difference we see in
Birken pain because that too expresses a
kind of desire to allow the freedom of
choice to override on chosen obligations
this is a this is a question that's very
hard for a liberal society to get away
from because the facts of human
procreation present challenges that
liberalism has a lot of trouble with and
it gets back to what we spoke about
before that the the thought experiment
of the state of nature is in fact
utterly implausible if you accept the
fact that everyone is born into a world
that exists before them that everyone is
born into a family that we're always
nested in this web of obligations and so
these things are deeply connected at a
level that runs I think much deeper to
the route and we're used to thinking
about and and shows you why things like
bioethics are worth thinking about from
the point of view of political
philosophy and why the kind of thin
ethics it's usually applied to
is not nearly good enough yeah I think
you said that there are some
Jeffersonian roots to progressivism and
through your point of view that
certainly makes some sense but when I
think of today's progressives I think of
incipient in Thorat Aryans because I
mean they're the ones who suppress other
points of view that they don't agree
with and you know and and and when I see
these people particularly when they get
in the power they want to eliminate
political opposition and things like
that I see what they do and that doesn't
seem to be consistent with what
Jefferson believed at all you know you
know what you find in Jefferson and in
pain and in a lot of the a lot of the
more radical liberals of the late 18th
century is a belief that liberal
institutions would lead us to an ideal
state beyond politics as a belief that
if you if you really apply the
principles of human liberty and equality
the social problems that we have would
would be solved in effect that we have
these problems because we've failed to
live up to these principles there's an
extraordinary threat of utopianism in
the radicalism of the of the age of
revolutions and again it feeds this
belief that any example of political
failure is an is an example of a failure
to live up to these principles and is
inexcusable because here are the
principles they're right there they're
very straightforward we can solve these
problems in the course of the early 19th
century as it turned out that these
problems were not in fact solved by
liberal institutions the left in America
and elsewhere but let's talk about
America faced a choice a choice between
liberal institutions the means that
Jefferson and Paine had in mind and the
utopian ends they had in mind the
liberation of the individual from
unchosen obligations the liberation of
society from its most profound social
problems
and for the most part over time
gradually the left chose the ends over
the means the Autopia nism over the
liberalism and pursued other ways of
achieving those ends ways that were much
more technocratic much more
scientifically minded than Jefferson's
had been and ultimately ways that were
deeply informed by European social
democracy but I think there's no
question that the thread that starts
with Jefferson in our country does
stretch to the progressives they're not
wrong to suggest as the early
progressives constantly suggested that
they were trying for an applied
Jeffersonian ism in their time in a
different time a time when say it was
necessary to protect people from abuses
by economic power and not just political
power if you read if you read Crowley
the argument that he makes is not
implausible it's not quite true either
the history that he gives of how he came
to his views but it's not crazy now it's
true that today's progressives tend not
to talk about Tom Paine right they tend
not to talk about the they tend not to
try to speak in the language of the
American Revolution very much they tend
not to be very interested in their own
intellectual history even recent
intellectual history I don't mean that
as an insult I think it's just true and
it's actually kind of in line with their
our self understanding as pragmatists
rather than ideologues of course that's
self understanding is itself an ideology
but I think the threat is very real and
I think what you can discover about the
right and left by looking at the way
that this very deep anglo-american
debate took place at the time of the
founding actually tells you quite a lot
about today's right and left because it
speaks to two dispositions that are
always part of a liberal society the two
ways of thinking about what we're up to
that are always with us even though the
the frames we put them in have changed
and conservatism changed a fair bit too
I think the underlying questions the
deep problems that this is about are
still very relevant so whether they know
it or not whether they like it or not
there is a threat running from the
radicalism of the age of revolutions to
today's progressivism I I don't think
it's all that hard to show ya there's a
book here yeah sentence by holding up
the book I should try to get used to
doing that thank you I'm gonna make you
take a prerogative here and ask you one
last quick question and press you a
little bit you might because we add
heels so we actually like the
Declaration of Independence
I love it quite a bit I just thought the
whole thing
wait this is my question is there not a
way to read the Declaration which is not
in its radical lock-in since it's
oftentimes perceived but in a way that
is actually more friendly to what is in
your reading a very burking way of
reading it which is it's deeply
influenced by religion and a theological
understanding of things and heavily
influenced by prudence which an odd way
would suggest that perhaps in the midst
of this debate we should be appealing
back to the declaration precise for the
reasons I think you want to yeah to
grasp which is where do we get back to
nature and our current conversation I
completely agree with that Jefferson is
not pain exactly and in fact the
Declaration is not Jeffersonian exactly
first of all as I said before the
declaration both states a set of
principles and states a set of reasons
for pursuing independence and they're
not identical the question of how one
leads into the other
I do think points more in a Burkean
direction than in a than in a highly
radical direction
the Americans were trying to preserve
their rights as Englishmen and trying to
preserve the system of government they
had had that they had inherited from
their English fathers the declaration
says so in those terms and so it
certainly has a a conservative face to
it I also think that the the frame in
which its its assertion of Rights is
placed is at least open to the kind of
reading that you're suggesting but I
would also say that the more radical
reading of the Declaration
in the reading of it as fundamentally a
statement of radical philosophical
principles is our fault more than the
left's fault it is something the right
is done to the Declaration for reasons
that are understandable but I think at
some level misguided we've done it to
Lincoln too we've come to see him as a
kind of radical philosopher rather than
a statesman a highly prudent statesman
well understood the principles that his
society had to live by understood the
essential need to offer continuity with
the Society's own tradition and showed
in practice how that can be achieved
I think conservatives need to rediscover
that depth of our tradition that thread
in our tradition I think that the
Constitution especially offers us a very
clear way to do that and you know the
Constitution was written in a much more
conservative moment in America than the
Declaration in a in a peculiarly
conservative moment a moment when the
public had rather rejected Jeffersonian
ISM for a minute
I think bringing out these threads is
not something that we ought to avoid
it's something that we ought to do we
avoided because it seems irreverent or
not sufficiently reverent of the
founders to say that they were deeply
divided among themselves along some of
these same lines but I think the
opposite I think to show the depth of
our own tradition to show the depth of
its contention with these difficult
questions helps to show why America
works
the fact is America has lacked a theory
of itself that is worthy of it and it's
up to us to to provide that to think
through what an actual theory of America
that's a worthy description of American
life would look like it's not one that
we have it's one that we need
you